je suis là oui je suis là laurent g mais
vu que ma voix a dû vous donner quelques
sueurs froides ou peut-être quelques
bouffées de chaleur rassurez vous j'ai
une solution pour vous solution 100%
naturel de la climatisation et ça prend
les armes encore plus de place qu'un
blog clim à votre fenêtre vous allez
voir c'est très efficace aussi favrel
chantal sept permis tiers c'est
finalement un système à lui seul de
climatisation en effet on a observé que
les termites avait d'aidés demeurent
particulièrement fraîche donc en
regardant on s'est aperçu qu'il y avait
des galeries qui allaient très
profondément dans la terre et qui
apportaient de l'air frais qui circulent
et qui dans des pays particulièrement
chaud rafraîchi leur habitacle d'accord
là on a fait quelque chose d'assez
gigantesque d'acheter imposant aussi
pourquoi y'a une porte et esthétique à
tout ça d'abord c'est une sculpture
destinée à faire comprendre que ce que
sont les les termitières il ya des
termitières énorme dans certains pays un
pays chaud et on voit qu'il ya qu'il ya
plusieurs plusieurs dimensions c'est en
terre crue accord les termites c'est
vrai qu'on a tendance à se dire vous
faut s'en méfier c'est dangereux ils
détruisent l'habitat en fait ils peuvent
aussi être une solution c'est ça qui est
assez fou c'est la complexité c'est
comme le champignon qui est à la fois ce
qui nous empoisonnent est exquis et nous
fait vivre les termitières sont
dangereuses pour le bois mais
l'observation comme on le disait de leur
habitat qui a permis d'imaginer des
architectures des des églises des lieux
où l'air c'est que circulent
naturellement sans ses moteurs qui
contribuent au réchauffement climatique
et donc c'est une très bonne idée que
nous ont donné ces animaux pas très
sympathique et des bonis
c'est ce que vous essayer d'amener aussi
avec ce festival avec ses jardins pas
simplement un constat triste est
alarmant de l'état de notre planète mais
des solutions à appliquer applicable
facilement je pense que on peut être à
la fois un lieu de création a lieu
d'observation des tendances du jardin
est un lieu qui fait réfléchir
on peut sans s'angoisser nos visiteurs
leur faire comprendre que l'observer sur
la nature peut nous permettre de trouver
des solutions et surtout donner un
espoir c'est très important
tout n'est pas perdu